the jurgen experience how do you feel
about um
about the olympics banning uh shakira
richardson
100 horseshit first of all i think the
olympics are disgusting
because that lady should be getting paid
millions of dollars all of them should
be getting paid millions of dollars all
the winners
the gold medals all those all those
people that are generating insane
amounts of wealth for the olympics they
should get a giant piece of that
they're responsible for the reason why
people watch the olympics no one is
watching the olympics because it's the
olympics they're watching the olympics
because you see the best athletes on the
world
right you see the best athletes who have
gone through
all these competitions and reached this
insane pinnacle of their skill
development right and they're getting
nothing
they're getting zero and the whole
world's watching and they're selling
crazy advertisement
and that money is being generated and
the networks are making it and the ioc
is making it and all these other people
are making it
and the athletes the whole reason people
are tuning in
they get nothing it's insane
it's a disgusting corrupt system gross
and then a lot of times the cities that
they move into like once they're gone
they fall the [ __ ] apart oh yeah yeah
well it's a lot of times you know these
countries they build up this whole
thing for the olympics and they're
incentivized and there's a lot of money
that flows into the city
and then once they pull out of that i
mean the people that live in that
country are like hey
why didn't you spend that [ __ ] on
infrastructure why don't you spend that
[ __ ]
to fix the bridges and the streets and
to you know to
[ __ ] fix these communities but
there's no money in that
i don't give a [ __ ] about you these
dirty [ __ ] but i i think it's
infuriating that this lady
who is apparently like she's a shoe-in
for the gold medal in the hundred meters
she's supposed to be spectacular and
they're not gonna let her run that
but they're gonna let her run the relay
like [ __ ] you
oh they're gonna let her run yeah
they're gonna let her yeah because if
she doesn't run the relay america
probably doesn't win
i mean i don't know i don't know about
track and field i think she's kept off
what yeah yeah what do you mean
exclusion from the relay team yeah i saw
that last night
oh this is new mm-hmm she's not on the
team but for weaving the weed
it's so dumb it's so dumb it's so dumb
look if they caught her doing steroids
or epo okay
i get it okay but man there was a lot of
people accusing her of steroids
there was like a lot of people accusing
her of a conspiracy so the reason why
she smoked weed was so that she could
get caught for weed and not get caught
for steroids like
i was reading this i'm like you've
people
can't just look at things for what they
are everyone has to like look at things
like with this conspiracy theory lens
yeah i mean that's just that's just
idiots yeah like
people that that pedal in conspiracies
and room
it's like they it's a substitute for for
doing the work
to become actually intelligent you just
say the opposite of what everyone's
saying
it is however track and field apparently
has been that one of the dirtiest sports
like they have been cheating from the
jump oh yeah apparently like
most countries cheat they try to figure
out a way to juice their athletes up
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre on your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience